you [ __ ] the tree once I know you did
Georgia [ __ ] [ __ ] weird [ __ ] right
what's the weirdest thing you [ __ ] I
once put out two two pieces of salami
between my couches cushions and I [ __ ]
the salami when I was a kid slicer thick
thin sliced I got a thick pickers piece
of steak oh yeah i nuked it
I made a vagina like how did you make a
vagina the Asians they go like north
south vagina so that's what that's B
you're going with right the east-west
excuse me east-west is that what it is
are we east was it's East Way it's like
a beaver yeah the vagina I never got
that I just say this right I never got
that because the thing is is that yeah
ours go east west but sooner your eyes
right eye are all the guys go the same
direction
stereotype I don't know now if an agent
woman's vagina slam well you're an Asian
are you oh you know so you got two
Filipinos a cream do you guys get along
I thought you guys didn't like each
other
Bobby has his thoughts on the
Philippines and then what is the
hierarchy of let me ask you the same
question let me ask you the question
we're third world what do you think the
hierarchy is between hierarchy is it's
gonna be Japan on top right Korean that
well I know but let me just say keep
that you're on the right [ __ ] path go
ahead let's guy go gotta go Korean yes
then it's a battle between korea it goes
he goes japanese battle between Korea
and China very good and then the rest of
them no let's go further okay be
specific okay let's go further
okay what your guess is not this is
racism just your gas we're educating
ourselves okay hating yeah so what Sam
Tripoli thinks is that
the only Asians right other Japanese
okay I'm just saying like history
throughout history Wars and who won Wars
exactly thank you so Japan number one
yes
you know you're right because they went
for it yes they do we wanted order China
they took down China dog they sent a
couple [ __ ] yeah and for be a little
island records it's unbelievable the
sunshine you go to China I do comedy out
there they don't like are you doing
jokes about Japan they don't like Japan
it's like literally like like going to
the United States to stand up and like
we got our asses kicked by Rhode Island
dog Japan is to China yeah it's huge and
this is tiny little place let's go back
to the list
Japan number one Japan number we're
saying there's a competition for second
and third yeah between China and Korea
yes
I'm Jerry very good okay what would okay
so what would be for now we're getting I
know we're getting into the bottom rank
the Southeast Asian so tired audience
Filipinos late and high women so I'd
like them to be pretty high up because
they have like the fattest asses of all
them girls Japanese girls to have
Koreans hmm
nope I like their karaoke love their new
karaoke like you go anywhere in the
world there's a Filipino karaoke cover
band yeah yeah yeah true we all export
something they do when I would have a
brothel in in a Kyle and called
Amsterdam yeah did a live female Asian
band Rob alright middle you're [ __ ]
killing it yeah and they're just [ __ ]
yeah Oh Beatles songs like just Care
Bears
yeah I mean and I would walk in there
yeah man yeah no wait a minute and get
my [ __ ] [ __ ] one get a puss did anyone
try to buy you cuz you look like a girl
at some point I remember when I first
met you with your hair people might try
to fight
[Music]